day-to-day living I find it can be
pretty mundane and you know when I'm out
there you've just got a really simple
task which is to survive and enjoy life
my name is Gavin McClurg and I'm a
cross-country paraglider we're basically
for flying and modified bedsheet and
strings we don't have a motor and we're
just using thermals thermals are kind of
like the gas for a car we get as high as
we possibly can and then we glide and if
we find another thermal we can keep
going I've flown in Himalayas I've flown
in Morocco a flown all over the Alps in
Europe in the Canadian Rockies and we're
just looking at a map in a completely
different way these days
hurricane rage is one of those
spectacular places for me in the world
is this beautiful long ridge that ties
right in with the Grand Canyon it sits
right on the edge as I on National Park
I was doing this expedition with some of
the best pilots in the world and right
is the Sun set you know the conditions
just went bang on and we all launched
into the sky and you know paragliding
can be really intense and sometimes
really scary and very dangerous and this
was like the opposite of that it was
just playful and fun and we were doing
huge wing overs and acro and when I'm
flying over these really remote places I
think what it gives you is a perspective
and an awe that is impossible to get in
any other way
these guys and I are people that you
know we really chase records and we
chase huge distances and made us realize
that you know it's not about the records
and it's not about flying huge distances
it's just about enjoying the freedom of
flight
you